one of the
names of Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
which every single Muslim knows. As a
matter of fact,
you have to know this name of Allah in
order to become Muslim.
And this is the first name we learn of
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala. It's his most
unique name of the names that we have
been taught.
Now notice I say of the names that we
have been taught.
How many names
does Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala have?
Somebody say something. How many names
does Allah subhanahu wa'ta'ala have?
Huh?
Usually people will
the first thing that comes to mind is
what 99 99 names the 99 names of Allah
those are 99 names of Allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala is not
quantified
by his creation or their vocabulary
subhanahu wa'ta'ala nor is he quantified
by their intellig igence or
understanding.
Allah subhanahu wa'ta'ala has
an unknown amount of names. Allah.
But of those names,
he has taught us 99 in the Quran and
Sunnah.
And these 99 names, they're not all the
same.
They are
of different types of different
categories
with different implications.
However, of all those 99 names of Allah
that he has taught us,
two of them are his most prominent
names.
Allah subhanahu wa'ta'ala mentioned them
together
in a closing verse of
He said, "Subhan,
those two names are Allah and Alman.
Those are the two most prominent unique
names of Allah. of those 99 names.
All other names of Allah follow those
two names.
Even in grammar,
even grammatically speaking,
Allah, that name of Allah, Allah and
Alman,
when they are mentioned separately,
they are never used as a description.
They are always used as the name and
subject of the sentence which all other
names work to describe.
So these two names of Allah are the most
prominent
which is why it is impermissible for
anyone
to name or have a derivative of these
two names.
We can name someone Abdul Rahman
and we can we can name someone Abdul
Rahim. We can also name the name. It's a
name. However,
we can also name someone Abdul Karim or
Karim.
However, we can never call someone
Rahman
and we can never derive from the name
Allah any other name for anyone or
anything else.
Allah Subhanahu Waaala's most prominent
name of all the 99 names that we have
been taught by Allah in his book and in
the Sunnah of the prophet sallall.aii
alaihi wasallam is his name Allah
is his name Allah
but what's interesting about this name
is that many Muslims
don't we really take this name as a
given we are taught the name of Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala we refer to him as
Allah but often times many of us do not
stop and think what does the name
Allah mean? What is the meaning of this
name? What is its etmology? Where is it
from? What are its implications?
This name
is the only name of Allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala which a person must know in order
to be a Muslim.
It is found in the first pillar of Islam
and that is that a person to become
Muslim enters Islam with the testimony
ofahill.
Soahill
what does it mean? This is upon which
all of our actions and worship is going
to be judged by Allah.
The name Allah
comes originally
from the root word in Arabic alah.
Elah
alah
literally translates to the one who is
worshiped out of love and exaltation.
Arab
[Silence]
thatch. for
the name
means the one who is worshiped. But
what's the difference between worshiped
and what is the the na the meaning of
mood and what's the difference between
those two words in Arabic? Know that
there are no two words in the Quran
and in general in the Arabic language
which are entirely completely synonymous
from every angle. They mean exactly the
same thing. There are no two words in
the Arabic language which are completely
synonymous
from every aspect, from every angle.
They may mean the same thing at their
core, but there will always be a
difference between any two given words.
And it's really that in any
language, honestly. Even in English. In
English, we may have two words that
mean the same thing. However,
just by the way that they are said, the
letters that are used automatically,
those two words cannot be completely
entirely synonymous from every aspect.
But in the Quran, there are no two
synonymous words. There are no
synonymous words entirely synonymous
from every aspect in the Arabic
language.
So what is the difference between
the difference is
means the one who is worshiped or
something that is worshiped. This is
referred to as a mud.
However, alah or anah in the Arabic
language
is that which is worshiped
with love and exaltation.
That is the difference. The difference
between mere worship and
is that worship can be with love or
without. With reverence without.
However, anah
is only that which is worshiped out of
love and exaltation. So the Arabs refer
to this as an
something that is an meaning that it is
worshiped out of love and exaltation.
And we know that in Arabic is worship.
The Arab The Arabs use this word in
their poetry. For instance,
[Silence]
So
is that which is worshiped out of love
and exaltation.
But the Arabs being a pagan society,
they had many aliyah. They had multiple
if you will.
And so they wish to differentiate in
their language between that which is a
mere idol or that which is worshiped and
that and and the one who is the creator
of the heavens and the earth and the
supreme
one who is worshiped,
the originator, the founder, the
creator.
And so they took
and they used it to describe
their idols. However, alah
the one who is worshiped
was only used to describe Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala the creator of the
heavens and the earth only. But just
in every language
when we use a phrase or a word and we
say it a lot and it is used commonly
we often times
start to
start to summarize the word or make it
shorter or remove letters in the word
that are kind of heavy on the tongue. So
for instance in English we say could
not. Could not. Could not. We say it all
the time. Could and not. They go
together all the time. So what did we
start to say? Couldn't. Couldn't, right?
We summarized it. would have, would
have, would have, right? Etc. So
naturally
as time goes on and people use any
language, they summarize. Well, the same
thing occurs in Arabic unsurprisingly
and that is that the hea the Hamza which
comes from the very base of the throat
is viewed as a letter that is very heavy
especially it is cumbersome especially
when it falls in the center or the
middle of a word and the Arabs have an
entire dialect based on removing ing the
Hamza and referring it back to its
original vowel. And so El
and they also would use it with calling
out Elah.
And so they dropped the middle Hamza.
Alah, they took that Hamza away. And now
they have three lambs in a row and they
put them together and they made one
heavy lamb and it's the only time in the
entire Arabic language where the lamb is
considered to be a heavy letter.
And so they made it one word Allah.
And that is where Allah that word comes
from. It captures not only the the
nature of Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala's
oneness but it as well captures the
right of Allah over his servants and
that is that he be worshiped alone out
of love and exaltation without any
partners. Subhanahu wa ta'ala. And so
this name was affirmed
by Allah Subhanahu Waaala in the Quran.
The Arabs, they had names for Allah that
they referred to Allah with. But then
they would also take derivatives of that
name and give those derivatives to their
idols. So for instance, Allah, they took
a derivative of that and called one of
their idols.
They had aliz and they took a derivative
of that and called another of their
idols alman
and they took a derivative of that and
referred to another of their idols as
man. not only a derivative but in the
feminine and in the female which is
something that Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
refuted
throughout the pages and throughout
the verses of the Quran. So having
understood where this word Allah comes
from,
now we understand in a more deep and
meaningful way the testimony that our
prayer will not be accepted without,
that our fasting will not be accepted
without, that our zak will not be
accepted without, that our hajj will not
be accepted without, even putting our
life down will not be accepted without
and that is the testimony ofallah
meaning none is rightfully worshiped
out of love and exaltation except for
Allah.
That word which the Arabs used which
inherently
does not accept masculine or feminine
that inherently
transcends
all other descriptions found in the rich
language of the Arabic language. So we
see that the Arabs subconsciously
in the way that they spoke and being
that the Arabic language is a seemetic
language, it is an original language
from which all other languages are
derived. It's one of the original
languages. We see that
it is by design
that the name Allah is only
is only appropriate for one subala
and no feminine can be taken of it.
There's no feminine variable variant of
it. Even though Arabic everything is
female or male except for this word,
there's no way to make it female. As
well, we see that the Arabs in spite of
all of their idols and in spite of all
of their fables and in spite of all of
their mythology,
yet they conceded whether consciously or
subconsciously
that Allah is one alone without any
partners. Subhanahu wa ta'ala. Which is
why the Arabs never held a belief in
their pagan times and in their pagan
days never held a belief that there was
ever anyone equal
with Allah or similar to Allah subhanahu
wa ta'ala in the creation of the heavens
and the earth. Yes, they worshiped other
than Allah, but only for the desire of
intercession.
That if I get on the good side of this
saint, this saint will put a good word
in for me with Allah. That was the idea
behind the worship of their idols. And
they would even say this in their like
we make for Hajj. They would say
They would say at your service, oh
Allah,
no partners unto you,
except for a partner that you own and he
owns nothing. So this addition here of
you have no partners except some
partners over here. This part was an
addition
an innovation
entered upon the religion of Ibraim.
Otherwise,
the original of Ibraim that he taught
his followers and children and offspring
and prophets and messengers after him
was
and so that part is correct. Islam
retained that and that addition of that
misconstrued and perverted belief
that was done away with with the u with
the revelation of the Quran and the
sending of Muhammad Sam.
We ask Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
that he subhanahu wa ta'ala teach us his
names and attributes that he teach us of
the Quran what we are ignorant of that
he remind us of it what we have been
made to forget and that he benefit us
from that which he teaches us of it
which